tout autre sujet à présent Faustine
aujourd'hui à Chambord avait lieu le 28e
défi inter entreprise d'agglopolis oui
cet événement est organisé tous les ans
par la Communauté d'Agglomération de
Blois plus de 2000 personnes
issues de sociétés locales s'affrontent
pendant une journée autour des preuves
sportives une manière de fédérer des
entreprises et donc le tissu économique
local Hélène chapelet et Lucas Chopin
était sur place
le départ de la course des trois
kilomètres 500 a été donné à 17h30 très
précise près de 550 salariés
Loir-et-Chériens se sont alignés juste
derrière moi devant la façade du château
de Chambord le défi inter-entreprise je
vous le rappelle ce sont trois épreuves
en relais une course à pied un parcours
de 600 mètres à deux en canoë sur le
Cosson et une petite balade en VTT de 7
km tout cela évidemment dans la bonne
humeur et sous les couleurs de
l'entreprise que l'on représente alors
avec Lucas Chopin nous avons rencontré
une équipe très motivée juste avant le
lancement des épreuves je vous laisse
faire connaissance avec Luc et Héloïse
de l'entreprise de Saint Michel moi vous
l'aurez compris je suis au milieu de
cane Barbie qui s'apprête à relever ce
défi inter-entreprise alors
expliquez-moi pourquoi cet accoutrement
Ken d'abord
bah Barbie Barbie on essaie de surfer
sur l'actualité le film le film à
cartonné on s'est dit c'est le film
carton bah nous on pourrait cartonner
aussi avec ce déguisement vous êtes
entraînés pour ces épreuves vous allez
faire le canoë si je si je me rappelle
bien oui c'est bien ça non je me suis
pas entraîné c'est difficile de
s'entraîner pour le canoë mais on va
faire ce qu'on peut c'est une première
participation pour vous première un
entraînement un petit peu un petit peu
on essaie de se dire qu'on va qu'on va
pas paraître ridicule lorsqu'on va
courir tout simplement il y a quand même
le concours du meilleur déguisement qui
qui est ouvert et je pense qu'ils ont de
grosses grosses chances de l'emporter
une fois le défi sportif terminé les
2200 participants et mes nouveaux amis
les Lego vont se retrouver à la salle du
Jeu de Paume à Blois ce soir et puis
sachez Faustine et Aurélien que j'ai
d'ores et déjà inscrite TV tour Val de
Loire pour l'édition 2024 et vous
connaissant bah je crois qu'il va
falloir vous entraîner un petit peu